oh yeah why you look so tired my dude
stayed up late watching new jack city
dead joint that fire ass quotable
Citroen $5.00 ass down before I make
change never liked you anyway pretty
mother brown Wesley Snipes to go white
men can't jump passenger 57 to Wong foo
thanks for everything Julie Newmar man
how you gonna name that Wong foo
and now drop jungle fever y'all don't
know
yeah jungle fever was my mama I
smoked the TV now pay attention to the
goddamn game damn milk I didn't know
junker fever meant so much to you yeah
we enjoy watching Snipes take down
Becky's as much as anybody no need to
get testy with whistling my bad y'all
I'm trippin uncle Joey got my twist
what you do now milk he awesome old send
me away cuz my YouTube show about to
blow you got a youtube show what's
it called
[Music]
you put baby powder in my blow dryer nah
I put blowing your blow dryer got you mo
melted get down here we're gonna be late
for synagogue the hell is this honey
why would melt ugh got you mom
get off the car you cracker-ass cracker
and loser run please don't work
knew you was a mark ass bitch come
yep gotcha that's ed bilder you're so
that square uncle Joey booted me sign me
up for the student exchange program Oh
for real forum Breezies love Americans
where he's sending you France Japan
swish man you bomber Stan damn milk
well I'm finna just pour our little son
for you now what's that supposed to mean
it means you better learn how to throw
rocks cuz your dad
[Music]